[Musica]
allora immaginando di camminare nei
corridoi di un antica biblioteca
migliaia di volumi alla vostra sinistra
altrettanti alla vostra destra
le luci sono un po soffuse e li siete
quasi persi mi sentite in un labirinto
a questo punto vi ricordate la fiaba di
peter pan
secondo scaffale a destra questo il
cammino poi dritto fino al tavolino sul
tavolino trovate un libro verde che
cattura la vostra attenzione lo prendete
lo aprite e leggete i primi vincono i
secondi passano
beh ovvio dite voi i primi per esempio i
vincitori di una gara competitiva in uno
sport
vincono i secondi invece quelli del
tempo passano girate pagina e continuate
a leggere
la brezza nuove gli alberi mentre tu
chiudi gli occhi poi ancora il tramonto
rosso sulla spiaggia su granelli di
sabbia
noi pensavamo un libro di poesia proprio
quello che stavate cercando
d'altro canto chi non cerca un po di
poesia nella vita a questo punto
incuriositi guardate la copertina in
cerca dell'autore
nessun nome una sola sigla e hai capito
subito che non è l'associazione degli
amici degli involtini di gallarate ma si
tratta di artificial intelligence
intelligenza artificiale
a questo punto un po di spaventata
perché come può una macchina a scrivere
frasi di senso compiuto
addirittura scrivere poesia quindi
prendete con voi il libro e continuate
la passeggiata in questa antica
biblioteca a un certo punto vi rendete
conto che non siete i soli ma vi è una
ragazza un po spettinata la gente del
paese
la chiamava un pesce fuor d'acqua
lei però rispondeva sempre che solo i
pesci fuor d'acqua vengano il cielo
ragazza ha con se tanti fogli su cui sto
scrivendo alcune cose incuriositi le
chiedete se può leggerli qualcosa e lei
prontamente lei prontamente dice è di
finezza che si distingue una persona di
spessore e poi ancora va avanti
quell'uomo era così onesto che anche il
caffè lo prendeva corretto finezze
spessore uomo onesto corretto
aprite così di nuovo il vostro libro
verde in cerca di qualcosa di simile
d'altro canto questo libro è stato
scritto da un intelligenza artificiale
programmata dai migliori scienziati e
ingegneri del pianeta
allora lo aprite e leggete era una
storia d'altri tempi
nata all'alba tra le nuvole il cielo e
poi ancora correvano le stagioni loro
passeggiavano tranquilli tra gli alberi
e i mirtilli
dopo questa lettura alzate di nuovo lo
sguardo e vedete sul volto della ragazza
un'espressione di superiorità come se le
frasi da voi appena lette sul libro
verde non fossero brillanti allora la
ragazza di interrompe li fa una domanda
gli chiede
sapete qual è l'invenzione più brillante
di sempre ci pensate un attimo ma lei
anticipa la notte brillante la notte
wow lei allora vi spiega che proprio
durante la notte che lei si mette a
scrivere e dice scrivo tutta sera e poi
smetto poco prima dell'alba prima che la
notte suoni le ultime note note note
prima che la notte suoni le ultime note
voleva dire prima che inizi il giorno
incredibile
allora voi con tono di sfida riaprite
questo libro questo libro verde d'altro
canto sottoscritto da questa
intelligenza artificiale iniziate a
leggere non contare sulle altre persone
di vita la ragazza
ognuno sa che lei li interrompe di se no
no
vado avanti io senti questa non contare
sulle altre persone dice lei
la somma potrebbe essere zero
a quel punto lei gli dice non solo sono
giochi di parola ancora semplice domanda
una semplice domanda può contenere della
magia
guardate qua pensate al vento quando di
notte soffia forte perché non sposta le
stelle
questa domanda è completamente
irrazionale è quasi ingenua però
contiene della magia sono come le
domande dei bambini quando i bambini
fanno queste domande mi stupiscono e
allora chiedete alla ragazza cosa sia lo
stupore è lei che sapeva rispondere solo
con le poesie vi racconta immaginatevi
di essere una riunione col vostro capo
lui li assilla di domanda di incalza di
domande e vi chieda che progetti ai
quali sono i tuoi programmi ai delle
strategia e voi rispondete un solo piano
e bianco e nero e lo suono tutte le sera
è da lì che capita che dovete arrendervi
in questo libro verde
ok se ci sono frasi di senso compiuto
ci sono anche poesia ma queste poesie
manca qualcosa
non riuscite bene a capire cosa è
qualcosa di velato impercettibile è
molto sottile che però rende unica la
frase che però vi stupisce però voi
siete persone concreta questa cosa
velata impercettibile invisibile non
riuscita digerirla volete un esempio
eccolo qua volete un segno una cosa
tangibile quel segno con l'apostrofo
rosso un errore è corretto per coerenza
quella posto fosse giudicato da una
macchina un errore gravissimo in
italiano il maschile non vuoi
l'apostrofo ma se leggiamo la fase fino
in fondo
capiamo che quello che la macchina
giudica un errore invece un uomo la
giudica come una licenza poetica perché
la frase in sé è coerente a questo punto
vi dirò il nome di quella posta
ha un nome particolare ma ve lo svelo
dopo ora usciamo un attimo dalla
letteratura e andiamo nel 1913 il nostro
protagonista è un pilota russo peter
l'estero non è un pilota super esperto
non a migliaia di ore di volo
pensate che l'aviazione è nata solo da
dieci anni sta volando un velivolo da
poco costruito e dietro a un nemico che
lo insegue e non vede l'ora di
abbatterlo a un certo punto dopo la
virata a sinistra poi una virata a
destra non riesce a seminarlo e quindi
rende la leva della flora la tira verso
il basso punta terra a questa velocità è
un certo punto arricchirla leva verso di
sé l'aereo va su dritto nel cielo a un
certo punto si trova a testa in giù e
poi riprende velocità e dopo pochi
secondi si trova lui a essere dietro il
nemico in una posizione di vantaggio
il nemico è ancora lì a chiedersi cosa
sia successo nel 1913 qui per nest ero
così fu il primo nella storia eseguire
un looping un giro della morte e di
altri esempi ce ne sono
pensate di chiamarvi lucio e vivere
negli anni 60
avete studiato di impressionismo al
cubismo nelle migliori accademie d'arte
del mondo
avete vissuto durante l'astrattismo e un
giorno vi trovate davanti a una tela una
tela bianca e fate un taglio quel lucio
e lucio fontana i tagli di fontana
qualcosa che non era mai stata studiata
ho visto prima pensate ad albert
einstein che immaginandosi di cavalcare
un fotone ha rivoluzionato l'idea di
spazio tempo
pensate che pochi anni dopo ha cambiato
il concetto di gravità
immaginando lui immaginandosi lui cadere
all'interno dell'ascensore nel vuoto
pensate a richard feynman un'altra
incredibile fisico che per sbloccare
calcoli complicatissimi si è messo a
disegnarli incredibile incredibile
la memoria ieri sera le ho detto di
ricordarsi di me
ah ecco cosa dovevo dire dimenticavo non
vi ho presentato il nome della ragazza
viene meno il nome di quel apostrofo dei
tagli di fontana di diagrammi di file
man hanno tutti lo stesso nome
si chiamano creatività
ma guardate bene dentro la parola al
centro trovate proprio ei ai
intelligenza artificiale
beh ci credo l'abbiamo inventata noi li
sfida invece a trovare all'interno di
intelligenza artificiale la parola
creatività
a questo punto vi dicono solo siamo
estremamente creativi ma lo siamo anche
una maniera incredibilmente efficiente
rispetto alle macchine rispetto ai
computer consumiamo molta meno energia
quindi siamo creativi a impatto zero per
ora vi dico che in realtà ho sbagliato
tutto perché vi ho presentato questo
scenario come se fosse la sfida una
guerra tra noi e le macchine invece e
questo l'ho fatto perché non gli uomini
spesso compiamo un errore abbiamo paura
del diverso e questo non capita solo nei
confronti delle macchine purtroppo mi
presento io mi chiamo cristiano se non
fisico e mi occupo proprio di
intelligenza artificiale
le frasi in verde è quella del libro le
ha generato un algoritmo da me
programmato le frasi invece della
ragazza spettinata beh quel lascio
immaginare a voi che le abbia scritte vi
dicevo prima ho sbagliato tutto non
dovrò presentare questo scenario di una
sfida tra noi e le macchine piuttosto
deve essere una collaborazione a me
piace vedere l'intelligenza artificiale
in generale le nuove tecnologie come un
nuovo strumento un uomo pennello con cui
dipingere le soluzioni ai problemi del
mondo alle sfide diciamo dell'umanità vi
faccio alcuni esempi anche per farvi
vedere che l'intelligenza artificiale
non è solo
oddio mi sta rubando il lavoro oppure
non è solo a consigliarvi il nuovo
prodotto su internet ma grazie
all'intelligenza artificiale
stiamo facendo tantissime cose stiamo
aiutando i medici a diagnosticare nuove
malattie
stiamo ideando nuovi farmaci prima
sconosciuti stiamo scoprendo in nuove
strutture nel nostro codice genetico
prima invisibili se prendiamo
l'intelligenza artificiale la montiamo
sugli aerei
allora riusciamo ottimizzare le rotte e
diminuire i consumi
se dagli aerei ci spostiamo i satelliti
come ha fatto la esa european space
agency riusciamo a monitorare dall'alto
per esempio lo spostamento delle nubi
la distribuzione delle piogge e della
siccità e queste c'è molto utile per
combattere il cambiamento climatico
grazie all'intelligenza artificiale
alcune città della cina riescono a
ridurre le messe del traffico in maniera
intelligente grazie all'intelligenza
artificiale riusciamo ad abbattere
barriere tra linguaggi diversi e questo
è molto utile a livello dell'educazione
per i paesi in via di sviluppo
ora mi viene in mente l'ulisse dantesco
nonché il motto della sissa di trieste
che l'istituto dove mi sono formato e ho
passato quattro anni fatti non foste a
viver come bruti ma per seguir virtute e
canoscenza quindi in quanto umani se
inseguiamo la creatività la curiosità e
la voglia di stupire e perché no anche
emozionare allora non dobbiamo temere
nulla perché le macchine come ho detto
prima potranno solo essere un nuovo
strumento con cui risolvere le sfide del
mondo con cui superare le nuove colonne
d'ercole
a questo punto vi dico che quella
apostrofo di prima è proprio la
differenza tra noi e le macchine e spero
di essere riuscito a farvela cogliere
perché alla fine le macchine sono fatte
di silicio di precisione vanno vanno
sempre dritta sono fredde e non hanno
sentimenti
noi invece noi umani siamo fatti di
sorrisi e silenzi sorrisi e silenzi
ma intanto ci piace anche ripetersi però
poi guardate quello succeda
i primi vincono i secondi passano
guardate cosa è successo quella frase di
prima quale in verde quella generata da
un intelligenza artificiale quella con
cui abbiamo iniziato tutto
l'abbiamo ora unita a una frase scritta
da un uomo creando una cosa unica
creando questa cosa unica questa
collaborazione è avvenuta anche una
magia
prestate attenzione guardate la frase
verde ora non ha più il significato di
prima inoltre ha una visione ottimistica
guardate i primi non sono più i
vincitori della gara i secondi non sono
più quelli che passano ora i primi sono
i sorrisi i secondi invece sono i
silenzi quindi unendo l'uomo le macchine
possiamo essere solo ottimisti perché i
sorrisi i momenti belli
vincono i silenzi gli aumenti un po più
brutti passano grazie
[Applauso]